chose rare ce jeudi au bundestag le
parlement allemand
alors qu'angela merkel détail les
nouvelles mesures prises la veille des
députés du parti alternative pour
l'allemagne interrompre le discours de
la chancelière allemande obligeant le
président du parlement wolfgang sch aux
bleus à remettre de l'ordre et menacer
les députés agitateurs 200 qui dans sa
déclaration la chancelière allemande
détaille les mesures que notre
gouvernement a adopté avec les
gouvernements régionaux en accord avec
notre constitution
un moment si vous interrompez le
président vous serez sanctionné
ça c'est dangereux ce mercredi angela
merkel avait demandé aux allemands un
nouvel effort national en leur demandant
d'éviter les déplacements inutiles bars
restaurants salles de fitness et de
sport cinéma et théâtre devront fermer
leurs portes à partir du 2 novembre et
pour une durée d'un mois
les écoles resteront elles ouvertes de
même que tous les magasins mais avec des
règles plus strictes macho et gérant
d'un bar à berlin et il ne comprend pas
cette nouvelle fermeture
je suis bien sûr choqué par la nouvelle
car nous avons essayé ces dernières
semaines et ces derniers mois de
développer à nouveau un avenir avec des
concepts d'hygiène avec nos clients nos
employés pour maintenir une vie malgré
le coronavirus et c'est bien sûr un choc
que cela soit maintenant remis en cause
pour aider les entreprises des secteurs
les plus touchés par la crise sanitaire
le ministre allemand des finances olaf
scholz a annoncé le déblocage d'une aide
d'urgence
allant jusqu'à 10 milliards d'euros une
aide insuffisante pour mike
ce ne sont que des annonces les aides
qui ont été disponibles jusqu'à présent
n'ont pas fonctionné pour le secteur de
la restauration ni pour les clubs ni
pour de nombreux autres secteurs
elle ne couvre pas complètement les cons
elles ne comprennent pas un salaire
d'employeurs cela signifie que pour les
industries touchées pour les
propriétaires des activités fermées ou
limitées dans leur fonctionnement
les choses se présentent sous un jour
désastreux pour le moment des mesures
qualifiées de dures et pénible par
angela merkel avec environ 11 milles
morts l'allemagne plus épargné jusqu'à
présent que ses voisins européens
connaît également une recrudescence
importante du nombre de cas quotidiens